Modern Warfare remastered brings a
classic shooter to the current
generation of consoles but it's also
making some changes I'm Tony and this is
your optional paid GameSpot news update
supply drops have been a part of call of
duty since advanced warfare and a new
update to the modern warfare remaster
has brought them back you can now
purchase supply drops with Depot credits
or Call of Duty points credits can be
earned in game but points can only be
purchased with real-world money the
drops contain the usual skins reticles
and camo patterns though these are also
obtainable by completing game challenges
or by crafting them from salvage
obtained an infinite warfare so you
don't have to spend money if you don't
want to Modern Warfare remastered is one
of several recent re-releases and we've
just revealed our top five reissues of
the year tune in to our game of the year
live stream on Tuesday December
twentieth at ten a.m. Pacific will have
all sorts of special guests and prizes
for you there and for all the latest on
call of duty you're already in the right
place
you